and aaron sanchez the pitcher will that
night aaron sanchez has done a really
good job for the giants one win one loss
through four starts a 1.83 earned run
average so here is charlie blackmon
left-handed hitter off to a painfully
slow start
getting only 148 in 61 at bats nine hits
is all
one home run
four doubles
the giants playing him to pull
0-1 pitch to him
is hit towards left center field it's
going to find grass and roll all the way
to the wall dickerson tracks it down
they're going to send krone mcmahon's
home cj's home two-run double by charlie
blackmon the rockies take a two to
nothing lead
and the pitcher for colorado is the
right-hander chi-chi gonzalez gonzalez
who has pitched against the giants
already once this year so the jacks have
two runners in scoring position for alex
dickerson they are trailing two-nothing
infield is backed up the 1-0 pitch
swinging a slow ground ball to first
breaking for the play this belt he's
going to score krone
part of his right gets to the ball then
he has a foot race to first base and
wins the race with dickerson but belt
comes in to score
an rbi round out for dickerson posey
moving over to third
so the giants are down 2-1
here's jason vossler the third baseman
bottom of the fourth inning giants
threatening with two down one and two
the count here's the pitch vossler pulls
one into right field that's a base hit
he got something to hit and he'll tie
the game maybe more duvon coming around
third he's going to run right through
the stop sign and he collides with ron
wotus
and the throw comes in dubon is tagged
out by 15 feet or more
he ran right through the stop sign and
then he ran right into his third base
coach
the run scored to tie the game after
that it wasn't pretty
they're gonna give vassler credit for a
double
so it's two to two
and everybody walking off the field will
go on
to the fifth inning wow i
i just cannot remember the last time i
saw that
after the collision he he might have
been out anyway he probably was going to
be but he was out by a lot after that so
the giants do score a two-out run to tie
the game
it'll be left on left alvarez
against ryan mcmahon mcmahon has walked
and scored last time up struck out
lefty versus lefty here's the pitch
fastball bounce right back to alvarez
he's got it runs it toward first and
then underhands to belt for the out
and he leaves
them loaded
three men left no runs
giants two rockies two chewed on nobody
on here
is brandon belt who
singled his first time up and scored the
giants first run
infield is playing him as a dead pull
hitter 2-2 pitch
swinging he smashes one to right field a
liner way back there and gone
over the willie mays wall and just
barely
into the seats and the giants are ahead
three to two
home run number four
the giants are leading three to two
don nunez
left-handed hitting catcher
against the left-handed jose alvarez
nunez led off the fifth inning with a
walk
he popped out to third in the second
inning
alvarez the one-two
bouncing ball up the middle on to second
for one bad throw to first base
and the giants give the rockies the
tying run as brandon crawford who hasn't
made an error this year
air mailed the throw over brandon belt
hilliard struck out in the second inning
struck out again in the fifth inning
he has contact there but fouls it off of
kerwin danley who goes down
kerwin who has been
injured before the home plate umpire is
down
kerwin has
taken a foul ball to the throat he is
dealt with
some concussion issues
and
that foul ball off the bat of
sam hilliard
caught the veteran umpire and crew chief
and ryan attiton
the young umpire in the group has
already left the field to go put his
gear on because they know that
kerwin is certainly not going to work
anymore tonight and you hope that he's
okay
he's up now in a sitting position
there are protocols in the game now
for
concussions where they will try to
ascertain whether a concussion has been
suffered but he might have even been
knocked out the way he the way he went
down
and he does
look like he's
a little bit groggy and we hope he's
okay
and he will go off he's walking under
his own power but
with dave greshner on
one arm and anthony reyes on the other
nunez the runner at first belt on the
bag with him
the one-two offering
in there strike three called a fastball
down the middle
third straight time that hilliard has
struck out
but the rockies get a run a walk again
turns into a run
rockies have three runs on only two hits
in the game
brian mcmahon will lead it off
here's the pitch ground ball into the
hole in short crawford far to his right
has it spins around the long throw to
first belt leaps to catch it comes down
in the bag just barely in time
and mcmahon is called out
what a play by brandon crawford
the rockies are going to use
garrett hampson as a pinch hitter to try
to get a rally started against
jake mcgee who's pitched so well for the
giants this year three to three the
score the giants
and the rockies inning number nine the
corner
infielders flores and
belt are halfway back floor is cheating
up a little bit at third and garrett
drives the ball to center field going
back at the wall dubois it's gone
touch him all time
garrett hampson
to dead center field
the rockies take a 4-3 lead
bard
against brandon crawford to try to get
the giants started here in the bottom of
the ninth inning giants trail 4-3
now the 1-0 pitch crawford swings and
there's a long drive to right if it's
fair it's gone it is a home run
hello san francisco bay
it's tied up
for the third time this year in this
ballpark brandon crawford has
electrified the fans in a game against
the colorado rockies giants have a man
on
as the potential game winner with wilmer
flores coming to the plate
barred
again with a two-strike pitch to flores
and this one is hit the left dazza on
the run
crashing into the wall makes the catch
for the second out oh jonathan dazzle
what a play
here's ryan mcmahon with daza still at
second in a 4-4 game in the 10th
0-1 pitch hit in the air
right center field all the way back and
it is over and out of here
two run homer for ryan mcmahon on a shot
to right center
and the rockies lead it six to four in
the 10th
batch eighth of the year krone with a
pair of walks a pair of runs scored and
he hits it in the air deep right field
back it goes another one over and out of
here
back to back with mcmahon
cj crone with his fourth of the season
and the rockies open up a 7-4 lead
bottom of the 10th rocky's got three in
the top half so the giants need at least
that many to keep this game going belt
will start the inning at second base
with posey coming up 3-2 pitch
driven to right
blackman is looking up and it's a fair
ball
belt is going to score
and the giants will send the tine run to
the plate posey's got his third hit
here's austin slater now with the
rockies up 7-5 in the 10th and posey at
first
slater's first pitch swinging ground
ball up the middle hampson to story for
one on to first for the double play
and the rockies get their first road win
of the season